county school district performing arts
teachers are adapting to distance
education
a news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us their efforts and working
together to make this year successful
[Music]
a new type of performing arts education
there's a lot of uncertainty because
we're like
redeveloping and recreating our classes
[Music]
paul clayman teaches guitar at del sol
academy this is my
fourth year and his first doing
full-time distance education
he met with me off campus because of
school coveted policies
bringing two guitars he tells me his
concerns
trying to reinvent how we're going to
provide these opportunities for our
students
clemens says performing arts teachers
around the district are talking with
each other
finding the best ways to do distance
education i know that people thought oh
my gosh the performing arts are not
going to be able to survive through this
but we're surviving we're thriving kim
ritzer teaches choir at green valley
high school
she says performing arts educators
continue to adapt
from learning new apps for virtual
performances to finding additional
resources
a lot of the music publishing companies
are letting us pdf the music so that we
can send it to the kids and
so they'll have it without copyright but
an issue for some educators including
kliman
inventory he has about 65 guitars for
roughly 200 students
clement posting about the issue online
and receiving
positive feedback even from zappos i'm
hoping that through this
you know hail mary process i end up with
enough guitars that i can pass them out
to my students
any extra that come in he plans to share
with other schools
ensuring students keep the music playing
at home
kristen drummond 8 news now kristin
thank you and for more information about
klingman the guitar teacher and donating
to his worthy cause visit our website
8newsnow.com